[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
this week is Mike Driver you may
remember we did an interview with him
some time ago he's a serial entrepreneur
all-round good guy and someone who has a
lot of very counterintuitive ideas so
Mike driver welcome back to trigonometry
I'm delighted to be back thanks for
having me again he caught him in too bad
the first time no it was great it was
great the first time and it's good to
have you back and one of the reasons we
wanted to have you back actually as you
and I were chatting on the phone the
other day and you were just talking
about the situation that we're in now
was a lockdown the government's response
to it and you were saying there's lots
of things that we could be doing that
we're not doing there's lots of things
that we are doing that we ought not to
be doing so what is your kind of outside
that take on everything what stands out
for you in the current situation well I
mean I think in terms of good news some
of the stats that coming through at the
moment things are starting to get better
the rate of infection the rate of
fatality as hot as horrible as it is is
just seem to be starting to decline
around the world so so I think I think
it's it's perhaps less bad than it was a
ringing endorsement of the current
situation so I guess I guess you know
we're in in lockdown and the debate
about that is largely irrelevant I think
a lot you know we are where we are I
guess do you think it was the right
decision to go into lockdown I mean I
I'm glad I didn't have to make it I
think I think as there is the captain on
the bridge it's very easy for
commentators to to criticize when they
don't have the responsibility for the
consequences of their actions I think as
they as the caps on the bridge you you
all kinds of conflicts information
coming through dynamic moving situation
a different statistics different experts
opinions and really it's very very
difficult and you've got to live with
the consequences of decisions and I
think very much that's the difference
between I think the sort of we had this
sort of panic brigade didn't we you know
shut down closed borders well I think
you know my first point I guess is there
is that panic tends to breed chaos and
calm breeds calm so I wasn't so keen
perhaps on some of the more you know
sort of those those people who came
along and sort of scream but we didn't
really consider the consequences off on
what we were doing and I think in some
ways we're still paying for not having
thought through the consequences of a
lockdown whether or not you agree with a
lockdown or you don't agree with a
lockdown the consequences seem to be or
not sort of been thought through as well
as they might have been yeah and you've
talked about the consequences of the
lockdown and we've just seen I think
it's literally today verdict Atlanta
verdict Atlantic Australia have gone
into administration we're talking about
Primark looking as if they're in real
difficulties oh it's just gonna
precipitate the end of the high street
as we know it because the high street
was already struggling and now this has
just been a further body but body blow
to them well I think you have to look at
sort of each business in it in its own
on its own previous performance so many
of you take verging for example I mean
it's been in its heavily in debt the the
latest accounts last published accounts
its heavily in debt in the first place
it leases on its aeroplanes it basically
survives as a business you know it runs
his business out of advance ticket sales
cope it was probably a convenient
problem for mr. Branson I think he was
in trouble anyway so so it's that kind
of leads into some of the things I think
that we're we're getting wrong or that
we need to really think about what we're
doing in terms of the way we are
supporting we are supporting businesses
because there's a very good argument to
say well if that business was in trouble
in the first place which you know it was
it was hanging you know easy easy it's
the obligation of the government to prop
it up I mean I see hoodies
these Ireland oh no that's wrong I mean
that's a liability that well how much
does it cost to run it you know yes it's
serious estimation yesterday should
probably cost a couple of million to run
it you gotta admire the chutzpah haven't
you and he says okay well I'll I'll let
you take the cost of my island as
collateral because always visiting it
for a while so so in that respect I
think I think there's some businesses
that were that are naturally or were
naturally going to fail and the danger
of course is he's bailing those
businesses out without obtaining equity
for the taxpayer so what you're really I
think saying is we shouldn't be bailing
out businesses that we're about to fail
anyway uncover some over the edge well I
think there's I don't think necessarily
we shouldn't bail them out because there
are other considerations to the economy
for yeah I think that leaves one airline
in Australia for instance or you know
which is a whole different problem
Australia's great mate who wants to
leave just stay home save lives enjoy
the good weather have a bar become but I
guess you've got to think about the job
so so it's not necessarily it's
difficult without without sort of
looking in context to decide whether or
not you know we should save this
business on that business but we should
certainly considering what sort of state
was the business in before and therefore
what kind of a deal can we as the
taxpayers get for whatever we decide to
do in order to maintain that business
trading and isn't it I mean you you
would know far more about this obviously
might because you're an entrepreneur but
isn't it the the state of a small
business that you survive month to month
really a lot of businesses depend purely
on their cash flow and if that suddenly
dries up then after a couple of weeks
you're in serious problems are you
well I think someday actually these am
and certainly cash is king
the only thing you really need to worry
about in in in most businesses that's a
significant turnovers is its cash flow
cash flow will will make a breaking
business I absolutely agree with that I
don't I don't think that once you get
past the certain level that the majority
of businesses live hand-to-mouth
actually think we've got a slightly
different dynamic going on and I think
this expose is one of the big issues in
the government's response to the crisis
with the co vid business interruption
blown they've got that right every
business on the Odin scheme which which
is delivered in the form of a loan so
entrepreneurial businesses and I think
that's a that's a major major issue and
I think it continues what we've seen
which which I would describe as a
breaking almost a shattering of the
Covenant between some citizens and
society and I think that started with
student debt so so you it's a little bit
like I always think we're student debt
is a little bit like the Catholic
original sin you know you if you want to
go to you know you're not born with sin
you but you're born with original debt
if you want to educate yourself and
similarly if you think about what
entrepreneurs do in the economy and the
way they actually do work is these
entrepreneurs will run their businesses
with an element of redundancy in it you
know they're looking to survive and they
will only take that on for investment in
productive equipments or people in order
to generate a return on what we're
asking entrepreneurs to do now is to
take that on for survival so that
changes the whole raison d'etre of
entrepreneurialism and what yeah
actually I think quite severe
repercussions going into the rest of the
economy so I think the entrepreneurial
people are the shock absorbers for the
economy and that's what this this
redundancy is entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial your own businesses tend
not to carry debt in most instances they
tear or they tend to carry very manual
there and
tend to be able to survive normal [ __ ]
yeah unfortunately nobody converts
survive the daily English of [ __ ] that
we've got now but we tend to be able to
survive that normal day-to-day but what
entrepreneur says and I think I said
these previously is they is they say I
don't know what shit's coming down the
road but I know it's coming so I'll have
some urgency in my business I won't be I
won't be too leveraged I'll have some
cash in the bank and I'll be able to
survive those unexpected and yet
moderately [ __ ] event what the
government is is suggesting is there is
the effect of the exchange of that
redundancy for debt which which changes
the way entrepreneurs behave but it also
takes away that shock absorber which
protects millions of employees in the
country from medium level [ __ ] so when
we get the other side of this and I have
to say if we ever if they ever
facilitate these loans into the
businesses which seems to be another
issue for the governments at the moment
you know I think I've kind of been
through three for those sort of authors
that everyone quotes as to which three
books or all does it be like of which
what mess are we in you know is it brave
new world is it covert 1984 but I'm
actually starting to think we might be
in Kafka so we've got is sort of
bureaucratic labyrinthine nightmare
where we're businesses you know you're
basically Joseph K trying to work out
how you can obtain this money and I
heard recently I mean it's his cough
breast if there ever was one of one of
the things that's preventing people
getting access to the loans was European
regulation
I mean we've left the EU you know you
just end up go around around so so this
is one of those consequences of the
lockdown you know businesses did not
government should they're the economy
down businesses didn't shut the economy
there so for me a much better way to
support the entrepreneurial world as
opposed to the corporate world is
helicopter money so it's direct grants
what what loans are going to do is
they're going to fragile eyes but very
very important part of the economy for
many years to come but also completely
change the bargain if you like between
society and business owners business
owners that you know they have to make
the payroll they have to do your jobs
that's all the stress of looking after
you doing your job making payroll doing
all the things that that business owners
have to do and now what we do is we add
a layer another layer of uncertainty and
fragility into their businesses and I
think this is a terrible mistake
Michael speaking of changing the social
contract and the social dynamics and
dynamics more generally do you think
that one of the changes that will happen
as a result of everything we're dealing
with now is a whole set of
transformation some of which are
entirely unpredictable at this point but
you know that up until now and probably
it's got worse now you know there was
the fact that you know half of people in
America I think couldn't absorb an extra
cost over 100 four hundred dollars right
so behalf of the country since you're
living with no savings whatsoever a lot
of the same kind of patterns and
businesses where there was very little
resilience particularly you know as you
make the distinction between corporate
and entrepreneurial we've been living
very much as if the good times will last
forever and winter has come you know so
what do you see is going to be the big
transformations that happen out of this
in a way that we live our lives well I
actually actually think there will be
what looks like a fairly rapid recovery
but in terms if you if you think of
markets for instance I think I think
it'll look because because most of the
money most of the stimulus like is being
funneled to the corporate sector and I
think you're gonna have post the lock
downs and once we start
and wine the lockdowns I think you'll
have that initial rush of deferred
spending but people haven't done for the
last few few weeks a few months I think
you're gonna have a little bit of that
carpe diem
where you know people perhaps have been
as somewhat restricted and and and I
guess they did the potential for this
ever happening again might might might
fuel that but I think what you what
you're going to have this going to make
the biggest difference to people's lives
is is I mean I you know I'm not an
economist I sit deny all economic
background but it's something they is
monetized debt spending so that's
essentially where governments spend more
in the economy than they we've moved
from it in taxation that spending is
funded by either direct funding from a
central bank or the central bank buying
more government Treasuries so so I mean
this is the I think we've spoken about
it before this is the political victory
of modern monetary theory so MMC so this
mmt is permanent government deficit
spending up until the point that it that
it causes inflation so I think I think
that that's like crack to politicians
because it basically means a politician
can promise anything without we used to
promise things are not deliver them now
they could promise things not whirring
out worried about how much they cost so
whether or not whichever side of the
argument you might fall economically on
mmt I think the the arguments been lost
and the politicians that run away with
that so that that's got some interesting
implications I think in the short term
pragmatically we have to embrace it
because without it we would end up in
sort of a 1932 start depression what
happens after that I think is is
is definitely going to be interesting
because my view is that is that when
governments have no discipline they get
less value for money for their spending
that's a really nice way of saying
people start to rip them off
what mmt needs is is it doesn't need any
wastage in the economy and I think
anybody who's ever operated in an
economy knows that when there's free
money around deception is Darwinian
humans will fight incredible in that
ways too so I think what you then that's
essentially in economic terms they call
that a de basements of money so so so I
think you will see initial and who knows
this goes on how long this goes on for
but certainly some initial economic
growth after all this is over
fueled by government deficit spending
fueled by this carpe diem and perhaps
this deferred spending but I think that
once you take that discipline away from
government we might have some
interesting times before Francis II I'm
sure he's got a question for you just to
put it into simple language for people
who may not be economists just to
translate what you said what you're
really saying is the government is going
to create ie print endless loads of
money and then a lot of that is going to
be wasted and stolen and we're gonna be
creating growth by printing money so
when you talk about the interesting
times I mean that is one of my kind of
looming foreboding sensors at this point
is that I'm having a great time as we've
discussed many times yeah but there will
be hell to pay at some point down the
line for all of us and I I just don't
see how they're one well I mean there's
some interesting dynamics going on the
moment that might protect us for a bit
longer so you've got you do have quite a
lot deflation deflationary or
disinflation pressure in the economy at
the moment so while that's going on
currently you you're gonna be able to
get away with with where this
[Music]
this type of spending you know I mean
obviously at the moment the the all
price went negative yesterday basically
on the basis that although people didn't
realize if they took delivery they would
actually have to store it somewhere is
actually a real thing not a thing yeah
so so I think when you've got those kind
of prices in the economy and again
you'll have people better qualified than
me in this particular area at the moment
as I said pragmatically we have no
choice to avoid a 19:30 style depression
we have to do this I think that in that
sense the fact that we do have a lot of
deflationary pressures at the moment in
you know the central banks think they
controlled inflation overall that by by
using interest rates so over the last
few years those [ __ ] it basically
offshoring everything to China and
reducing the price of everything or
subsidizing the price of the taxi rides
bye-bye uber
yeah III long thought that ceasing
quantitive easing would lead to
inflation because everything would have
to be priced normally but so but I think
it going off subject I think that we do
have a a window to to perform this
society's type of operations well I
think we've got a problem is that it's
crack the politicians never be able to
let it go because politicians want some
promise thinks the voters in order to
the voters to I mean I think am I going
to say this out loud in somewhere I can
never delete I think is a very possible
that Trump will cancel student debt in
America really well he'll do anything to
get the second term if the polls aren't
worried wants them to be why not
we're we're writing checks for
everything else he's writing checks for
the old oil patch today airline industry
yesterday why not who knows but but I
think that the the scope it's almost
like left the right doesn't matter
anymore
yeah this scope to curry favor
means that we are we are now in a in a
amounting world yeah and to quote Top
Gun easier and I never thought I'd do it
on this podcast but I'm going to just do
it because it makes me think that I'm a
fighter pilot but it's true is therefore
what you're saying is that politicians
are writing checks their body can't cash
basically well well nobody's actually if
you think about it it goes back to the
consequences argument Trump's only got a
four-year term after this election hmm
will he bear the consequences of the you
know whatever the denim on to steal a
french phrase by the only French word
I'm gonna ask me like means but it
sounds obvious he's probably not gonna
be around he's certainly not gonna be
unlikely to be president when it
happened so so I think I think that's
actually that's actually one of the big
issues here is the consequences of this
won't be borne by the people who make
you make the decision
so you see SEO saying that essentially
it's a short termism that we're sort of
breeding now well we're we're giving
people who's raised on d'etre to be a
alive is power mmm lever to get
themselves power I don't think they
think past that means whether their
short term long term a medium term they
just want the power that means justify
the ends I think you're being very
unfair Jeremy Corbyn is a sane and would
have done wonders but anyway since we
are in the political realm now you and I
were chatting about the fact that you
know the journalists haven't covered
themselves in glory during this time and
you you were saying you felt like you
know Dominic Cummings and the team
behind number 10 had played it very
cleverly to the point even where you
know young members of your family were
starting to feel sorry for Boris Johnson
well don't you think it's the most
amazing thing
most people have sat at home and they're
looking at the TV and every night at
4:30 or whenever their the update show
is and they're turning to each other on
those sofas and they're saying why are
these nasty journalists being horrible
to these nice politicians how has this
happened and I may I presume it's
Cummings it could be it could be anybody
I guess but but they set the trap didn't
they they've been they've been like
ultra considerate flight and at the same
time and I think this goes back to what
I was saying before about how how easy
it is to be critical when you're not
responsible for the consequences of
action and I think that that that's
really the thing that people have sat on
the sofas and and anybody who has to
make decisions and everybody has to make
key decisions in their lives where they
balance pros and cons where there are
conflicting interests compromises where
they make sacrifices and they know that
nothing is black and white and yet we
have we seem to have the press who who
everything is a gotcha or everything is
seen in black and white terms and I
think people just have found that very
difficult and you and yeah I mean when
my 17 year old daughter says Boris
Johnson is cute
you know the press are getting it wrong
though Mike we're talking about public
perception in public perception of Boris
Johnson I want to move a little bit
towards China has this fundamentally
changed the way we perceive China the
way we perceive cheap goods that they're
producing or do you think once we get
back to normality it will be business as
normal well I mean globalization has
been I'd say probably the most important
force in in our lives and I mean if the
arguments of moments only wrap around
medical around protective equipment and
so on and so forth and
and should we could we see some of this
on shoring back into into the UK or the
Western countries my gut feeling is not
that we have tremendously short memories
money talks
it's a it's a big subject when you think
about what what we actually lost because
we lost a lot more than the ability to
produce medicines and we lost a lot more
than the ability to produce protective
equipment just to take those two
examples those two jobs who have jobs
that people added a tremendous amount of
pride in so well economically you may
say well you earn the same money in a
call center as you weren't producing
antibiotics well actually you know when
I went to my factory and produce
antibiotics and I came home in the
evening I felt good about what I
contributed to society and perhaps there
was much more for me as the as the
employee in what I did than the actual
hey maybe I go to a factory making
antibiotics and be happy to earn less
than I would in the new economy
whatever is those so I think we lost a
lot more and it would be great if if we
did see some of those activities coming
back it would potentially be
inflationary I guess so to go with the
the monetized spending debt expenditure
that the government's were doing we'd
have another inflationary contributor to
the economy my suspicion is I I'm not
sure we'll see how how much they want to
get into it with China on this nothing
because surely the u.s. in particular
Trump who's notoriously skeptical about
China
what he see this is an opportunity to
actually really attack them and try and
make some wholesale changes to the trade
deal that they have I think I think
that's I think he will want to look like
he is but that's
difference of actually changing the
terms of trade if you like and I think
that that cook the corporates the
corporates that we're talking about
before the corporates that I think
you're going to do very well from from
this recovery I think they will resist
that I mean apples supply chain is is a
good case in point isn't it be out be
you I don't know riche or Foxconn into
into the US how do you tell people that
their iPhone that cost eleven hundred
dollars now across two thousand dollars
I think these are very very difficult
things to imagine happening in in any
more than a superficial way maybe for
some things around sort of critical
surprise I think that it it's possible
but I don't see it happening on a large
scale I think it also depends a lot on
what happens and what we find out about
how the virus started and how it was
spread so if it you know there's a lot
of talk now is that this may have
escaped from a lab in Wuhan and there's
a lot of talk about China suppressing
information from getting out in order to
hoard ventilators and PPE right they
were not allowing American companies
that make PPE to export that PP in
January and February before we were all
aware of it so how we respond to China I
think will depend to a large extent on
what the public perception is about you
know is China a good faith actor or not
and I think increasingly we're starting
to see that they're not and you know
when we talk about antibiotics and stuff
I mean that is an issue of national
security really at its core right if one
country can switch off your supplies of
antibiotics and PPE and whatever else
that you know that's a problem that's a
problem I wonder how significant it is
even if that did come back in some shape
or form how significant it would be and
I guess no buts the effort that started
a viewpoint no Konstantine he's is there
isn't it implicit assumption you know
that we ever know what the truth is we
ever get to the truth I mean
that seems to be one of the
characteristics of the of the world we
live in at the moment is that there's
just too much information
yeah and so how do you ever know which
which the true or what the true
information is I I agree that it should
happen I just dancing with and I was
talking to a friend of mine who's
actually an entrepreneur and he was
saying to me that he thinks of what
we're gonna see is very much like the
AIDS pandemic there was a world before
the AIDS pandemic and then there's a
world post AIDS pandemic do you sort by
into that world view might that we're
gonna have a world which is pre covered
and now post covered where everything
has been changed as a result of the
experience that we've gone through or is
it too early to say do you think I from
our last podcast that when I say that I
think I said in the last podcast that
they the problem with predicting the
future isn't that we don't have enough
information today it's that the future
is unimaginable and if you you know I
think we we last spoke a year or so back
and in in some ways that statements is
like you get the credit or I find well
done you know shits coming but you don't
know what color is and again it applies
again here my instinct is things aren't
possibly changes as much as as people
think you have that kind of immediacy
that bias don't you that the things that
happen to you day today become far more
significant in and you you imbue them
with far more significance as I
certainly think you would have got long
odds on the thing that every single
person in the world's talking about
being a virus it's a bit disappointing
how if you said to me what is the one
event that could stop the world who get
every talkie I would have said a
visiting alien much more fun as well as
long as they were friendly aliens that's
that's a good point actually no the fact
that we can't imagine what is going to
happen but let's say you're at you
you've you you have a business how would
you deal
with this particular situation if you
could give advice to the entrepreneurs
out there what would you do in order to
limit the damage of this kind of event
we saw anything that you can do well
that's what I have that's what I have
been doing over the last few weeks and
it's it's very it's very case-specific
and and and the government you know I
think it's interesting you know when mr.
su nack turned up in his skinny tie and
he's nice see he really looked like he
was he was going to deliver didn't he
and and then when you sort of scratched
the surface of what he said it got it
got more and more complicated and I'm
gonna I think it's it's interesting and
I like to take that question is slightly
different direction so I I have been
advising businesses specifically we
moved a business that has a hundred and
thirty-odd stores in the UK we managed
to move a significant proportion of
their their sales online at a higher
margin which which we think ultimately
will will save the business and will
save somewhere in the region 700 jobs so
it's a very specific piece of advice for
that business and that that that will be
repeated you know what can we do how can
we think differently how can we think in
the Boxster now be very very
case-specific you know well I think the
problem we've got at a macro level is
what I would call the goldman sachs
problem so so everybody who's involved
in in the delivery of this from the
government is goldman sachs hedge fund
you know and they they they might as
well be from another planet-- when it
comes to entrepreneurial ii run
businesses you know when you get the
train from Houston to Manchester for the
conservative conference and you've
worked at Goldman or your words at a
hedge fund and you now a newly minted
Empire a newly minted advisor though
industrial estates you go past on the
way up there in another galaxy there on
the outer rim you know you've no
experience of the stresses and strains
so why this is again another question
why have we not got somebody from the
small and medium-sized business arena
involved in the delivery of help because
while those of us who do give advice to
businesses are able to look in the Micro
there doesn't seem to be anybody with
experience in this in this area advising
the government's on the macro and this
goes back to where we need to how we
need to deliver the money in the way we
can deliver the money and I think that
what they should have done and if anyone
listens to this with any influence is
they really easy and quick way and
relatively fair way to help businesses
now would have been a would have been to
reverse last year's PA ye and ni
contributions in business up to a
certain size so that would have been
immediate cash injection into into every
company in the UK and he would have
elements of fairness about it because it
would be pro rata it will be on a per
head basis PA Y in and IP businesses
employ more people would have would
received more support and that would
have been a really quick easy way to
helicopter money into businesses that
most need it without changing their debt
profile without changing their risk
profile without changing the way that
they do business and then to give them
the cushion so then think about how can
we can we deliver our service during
this period and how did we come out of
this period at the moment we we've got a
as I mentioned this this cafe esque
labyrinthine trying to deliver a loan
scheme through the banks banks asking
for personal guarantees you know a book
two hundred and fifty thousand pounds
they they want to closely guarantee all
of these things are changing that
covenant between entrepreneurs and the
wider society I Anna is it because they
don't understand
the difference between the corporate
world and the entrepreneurial world so
the corporate world corporates are much
more able to access aid much more
adapted to trading with a heavy
leveraged heavy debt
whereas entrepreneurial people don't
that's not the way that's not the way
they do business and yet we've got
people who are from that corporate world
that goldman sachs world I wonder if
they just don't understand the dynamic
the difference in the diamond dynamic
between since you sexes that is what it
would appear unless you of course you
considered this is something I think I
don't really tweet very often these days
but I think that's we did write the
beginning of this that the measures that
the Chancellor as an active will
represent the biggest transfer of
business from small and mid-sized
companies to corporates in history and I
still stand by that now unless they
change the way they're going to deliver
this aid we will end up with and then
this goes to what sort of world we were
living we will live in a world with less
companies and do you think that is a
fundamental failure of the Conservative
Party the way they've done under I
wonder if it's a bug or a feature all
puns intended yeah absolutely that that
makes a lot of sense Mike one of the
questions that somebody asked us when we
were doing our last livestream which are
actually the question if you remember
that we always asked at the end of our
interviews was what's the one thing that
we're not talking about that we ought to
be talking about and my instinctive
response was some of the winners and the
positives out of this now obviously it
sounds like one of the winners in your
opinion will be the you know the
transnational corporations which I would
say it's a negative outcome but what do
you see
who are going to be some of the other
people that do well out of this and some
of the positives that come out of this
because no matter how bad a situation
there will always be people who do well
out of it and there will always be no
new new industries new creativity new
technology that comes out of a new ways
of doing things you know are we going to
commute less are we going
pollute less are we you know what are
going to be some of the positives that
you see coming out of this well I think
we were we were headed in very quickly
in the wrong direction there's a species
I think I think Darwin said that the you
know that we we need its the checks on
our expansion that stoppers using up all
of our resources and becoming extinct
and I think in a way we had become too
adapted or over adapted to to our
environment which means that we were
basically going to deplete all the
resources until we were gone I mean you
haven't got vegan on in terms of micro
macro in a macro I don't think we were
going in a very good direction so so you
could almost say that anything any
change anything that causes us the cause
in in the direction that we're headed
has the potential to be good and I think
I don't know it's difficult because for
most people now they'll be very very
worried about you know their jobs about
money and all of the things and their
families and the opportunities going
forward so so he I don't want to
exaggerate the possibility for personal
development from this but I suspect that
that hopefully there's enough people and
having as the potential maybe for what
you're looking for is that people have
have had time to suppose and think about
think about what's important that may be
a full on hope for the human species but
that I guess that's the hope and it
might can you see a time where actually
because we're going through this
experience now and it's making us
reevaluate a lot of our lives like
things that you
question we suddenly really like
commuting going 40 minutes to a place
and coming and then go into an office
and 40 minutes back running your own
business surely there's gonna be a lot
of people gonna look and think some
subchannel why am I paying for office
space this is a complete waste of money
when actually the vast majority of
people can work remotely they will be
more effective they'll be happier and
that means that I'll be sober a whole
ton of money well I think again I think
maybe it's a little bit even deeper than
that
so I agree with you that people don't
want to Kim you and I think 40 minutes
is a generous estimation of most
people's Cuyo in and out of London
people are doing 2/3 for our our
commutes and I think that's that's
fundamentally destructive in so many
ways but I don't think people want to
work at home either I mean I've done
about anybody else but you know I'm
surviving here we all feel for you
Michael
but I think I think people would like to
live in environments where where they
worked and where they lived where within
walking distance you know I think you
sort of get under the skin of how we
designed designed our cities and and
designed our lives and the basic
architecture of the way we conduct
conduct ourselves and that I think what
those bows is that isn't working so it
would be great wouldn't it is if you
could you know walk 15 or 20 minutes to
to your place of work go home at
lunchtime leave work when you needed to
do something urgent go back to work and
that kind of dynamics somewhere in the
middle if you like if you're the
commutes but perhaps not you know it's
good it's good to get I don't think
there's going to be something positive
gained I mean somebody said to me
somebody asked me the other day what do
you think the future that like and I was
I was bastardizing the old world quote
from 1984 and and I said it's a it's a
laptop screen smashing you set you in
the face forever I'm not sure that
sitting you know or obviously
glued to this screen is necessarily that
healthy either so so somewhere in the
middle but I'm not quite sure how we get
there no because I'm sorry constantly go
ahead make because it just seems to me
that this way that we're living it
doesn't seem sustainable if you go back
to you know the nine-to-five and it
didn't seem looking back on it that it
was particularly effective either but
you know people had done it for
generations therefore we carried on
surely the next generation of innovators
and people coming out of it are going
well we've actually managed to break
that now we've seen that it doesn't work
therefore let's try this new money well
I think we'll definitely have I think
one of the economics effect on an
economic effects of of this situation
will be the relative growth of the
virtual hmm over the real if you like so
the virtual economy over the real
economy so so so you'll see more cloud
based activity more remote activity and
certainly if you think about contingency
planning for businesses now where they
used to have warehouses for the desk
they want to go to that's that's gone
now hasn't it so there's going to be a
whole different whole different way of
thinking about how you how you plan for
this kind of emergency or this kind of
this kind of interruption business
interruption going forward so I think
that I think there will be changes and
people will work from home or I'm just
not sure we'll get to that fundamental
change that that that is necessary which
is is more holistic it's it's the
context of our lives you know it's the
big thing that I think is even
underlined even more is is the
technology is not saving you anytime
it's not making you any happier you are
constantly available I mean the whole
worlds on shutdown and yet everybody's
cooped up in a room somewhere you know
talking into a team school it's not
improving our lives it hasn't
it hasn't given us any more free time so
so is it do we need a much more
fundamental reset I don't know something
more for another more fundamental virus
to show even more that's what we need is
what is what Mike is exactly what he's
saying but Mike what is it that we're
not seeing what is it that we're not
talking about what do you with the kind
of totally different mindset to most
people that I know what what is out of
our field of vision that's coming well I
think one of the consequences I mean I
think people are talking about this but
that my my biggest fear and it's not my
biggest fear for the economy or the
country maybe the biggest video for the
country he's the Civil Liberties
implication of what will come after this
i rushing a vaccine through that's a
frightening prospect in many ways backs
and i vaccinating many young people who
who don't necessarily need a vaccine is
concerning thinking about how you're
going to be monitored how you're going
to be tagged how your movements are
going to be Big Brother's I think all
these things I think Jeremy Bentham and
the concepts of the people's behavior
changed the panopticon if they watched
all the time their behavior changes and
I think that's quite dynamic amongst
populations as well I think for some
people for many people and it kind of
goes back to the the Huxley and the
brave new world view of where we are is
they ease they may embrace that they may
embrace that that that's sort of
monitoring that herding to use the
phrase in a different way well there's
many many other people and other people
that affect change who we're going to
find that intolerable so it took
breaking the law to change many of the
things that we now take for granted be
it suffragettes or homosexuality or many
of those things it took people you
who are prepared to step outside the
boundaries and similarly the way the way
most entrepreneurial people think is is
is to be is to be outside of the
mainstream and I think if we limit that
and I think that his daddy's perhaps the
thing that worries me most is we will
limit the ability of those people who
affect change to do so
and so where where will that where will
that leave us in a very homogeneous
world that's not a world I particularly
want to live in Mike well let me push
back on that a little bit because as you
know I you know if there was anyone who
was concerned about the erosion of our
civil liberties restrictions of free
speech that's me I've been pretty
outspoken about this for a long time but
I've got to be honest for you I don't I
look around I mean yes in Australia
they're talking about some kind of app
to track your immunity status and and
that would be a hill that I'm I'm
prepared to die on I'm not signing up
Jenny [ __ ] app that tracks me around
the country no way but what if you don't
what would you write that's it but this
is yeah I mean yeah this is my point
yeah so do you your passport is
dependent on you carrying your contact
tracing out yeah then then most of us
would and its erodes doesn't it so it
starts with a contract tracing out where
does it go after that right but my
broader point I mean I take your point
on that and that is I step way too far
in my opinion but more broadly speaking
I do see the you know a lot of the
people we've had on the show who we like
and respect kind of in my opinion going
way off the deep end on this stuff and
talking about how we're all under house
arrest and all this cut which i think is
a massive exaggeration I think a
temporary and necessary lockdown is not
the same as house arrest I personally
don't feel like Western governments have
been overly restrictive about this in in
proportion to the threat that we're
facing you know it is a warlike time you
accept a little bit more imposition on
your freedoms during that time provided
their time limited provided their
specific provided we can go back to you
know having a free society
afterwards I do you see signs that
not going to happen is what what's the
reason for your concern I never trust
people empowered to give the keys back
once once once once they get was similar
to the the MMT conversation that we had
earlier once you give people in power
power and consider that their their
reasons for living all the odds world
same power they really don't like giving
you back so I I die do I well I might
not be at me the further end of the
spectrum of the previous guests you've
had a we we as a country as a species
have fought and lost millions of lives
to maintain freedoms and I don't think
that should be lost there are
consequences there's serious
consequences to giving up giving up the
things that that enable is the change
and I think that's that that's what
scares me most is when you have a
contact tracing app that you need to
have you have you've given the political
order a lever in with which to dictate
or with which to demand your your
obedience and anything that does that
anything that does that more I think
that's that would be very very worrying
and you say you die on a hill for it but
the reality is most people won't I know
when most people won't you'll be you'll
be in the minority and then your wife
will want to take a nice holiday
somewhere and your kids will be saying
dad's an idiot what difference does he
make and compliance will become the norm
and that worries me I like the fact that
we're talking about this but for China
it's just business as normal is that I
mean that's basically what they do over
there so you know that just don't don't
say stuff like that in your accent
please
it's just what they do over there me
helps we're gonna be banned off YouTube
forever now Mike listen for your time we
really appreciate it and you're kind of
counterintuitive ideas and a slightly
different look at things as always is
always brilliant so we really appreciate
you coming on I would tell people to
follow you on twitter but you don't
tweet very much anymore follow all right
so remind everybody your Twitter handle
before we let you go don't be so long no
completely what is Mike that's MD Beck's
yeah at any vague so we'll make sure we
get that right in the video description
thanks for coming on Mike it's a
pleasure as always and we'll see the
rest of you with another live stream
tomorrow thanks for watching guys as
always subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pod and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word